say we're given these three points 0:11
one five and two three now the equation
of a parabola can be written in its
general form like this y equals ax
squared plus BX plus C so what we're
going to do is we're going to solve for
a B and C okay so what we need to do to
solve for three variables is we need to
have three equations so let's see if we
can write the three equations so these
are our x and y values so when y is 11
right X is 0 so that's going to be a
times 0 squared plus B times 0 plus C
right okay good and you can see that
anything times 0 is going to be 0 so
we've already solved for C so C is 11 ok
now the next one if Y is 5 when X is 1
we have 8 times 1 squared plus B times 1
plus C or if you simplify this this
would be like a plus B plus C equals 5
ok and then the last one when Y is 3 X
is 2 so we're putting 2 in for X so
that's 2 squared plus B times 2 plus C
and if we simplify this down we get 4
times a plus 2 times B plus C equals 3 I
just flip the equation to put the number
on the right side okay so you're with me
so far so we have three equations and
we're trying to solve for three
variables now this one worked out kind
of nice because we already know what C
is it's 11 so what I'm going to do is
I'm just gonna put the 11 back in here
for C and then what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to subtract it from both sides
sorry with me so far so if I put 11 here
and I subtract 11 that's gonna be
negative 6 so we get a plus B equals
negative 6 and over here if I put in 11
and subtract that's going to give us
negative 8 so we have 4a plus 2b equals
negative 8 so now we're down to two
equations in two variables so let's say
we want to eliminate the bees let's
multiply this entire equation by
negative 2
okay negative 2 if we distribute we're
gonna get negative 2a okay minus 2b
equals positive 12 right positive 12 so
if we add these together you get 2a the
B's cancel and we get 4 and if we divide
by 2 you can
see that a equals two okay now how do we
solve for B well we can put a back in
here or here or here any one of these
equations that has two variables let's
put it in here so if a is 2 we get 2
plus B equals negative 6 subtract 2 and
you can see B is going to be negative 8
so now we have a B and C we can put it
back together into the equation here so
we've got y equals a which is 2 so
that's 2 x squared B which is negative 8
so that's negative 8 X plus C which is
11 and we have our equation in the
general form y equals ax squared plus BX
plus